Let's test audio.
Please get out of my body, please!
It's a body!
She's taking me over.
Help!
It's a man!
Look, I can wink.
No!
Stop!
I'm taking over the body!
It's horrible.
Can you all hear me close enough or should I come closer?
Go a little closer.
Sorry.
You want me to come a little closer to you?
Not to me.
No.
Please get out.
Welcome to the maid cafe.
Oh, now you're in my body!
No.
Oh, you are?
No, it's only you.
It's only you.
No, you can.
Here, possess me.
Hi, honey.
She's possessing me!
Wisps!
Wisps, help me, please!
Please help me!
Sorry, guys.
This is just how it's going to be when you're in the vicinity of a space cockroach and a ghost.
It's just strange things happen.
Can I call Mint a stinky?
Yes.
For $20, I will call her a stinky.
I'll give you a bargain.
For $20, I will call also both her cats stinky.
Okay, but I don't need any money for that.
You know.
Also, can I please call you out on this?
So, her monitor is very big and her chat room where she reads the Wisps is so small.
Deal?
It's not even that small!
Stinky!
Hi, Matara.
Please call her stinky.
Stinky!
See?
You're still able to read it.
But I'm focusing on it.
Y'all don't understand.
Oh, so she's saying she doesn't focus on you guys.
I have to...
I don't know them.
They're strangers to me.
What?
I don't know these guys.
I'm not parasocial with them.
I'm parasocial with the momos.
There are 100% momos in this chat.
Also, stinky!
Stinky!
I'm calling you stinky.
You're like the little sibling that's playing along but you don't know what we're saying.
Stinky!
Mint stinky!
Thank you, everybody.
What do you think of my setup besides judging my monitor sense?
Well, I think it's very cute.
I think your setup is very cute.
I think your whole room is very cute.
I like every... I told you, I think you have a lot of really, really nice stuff in here.
My favorite is probably the Ketopi cinema roll with Metal Gear.
I love it.
I have a plushie of cinema roll dressed up in Ketopi's clothes.
Like the Sunreal characters.
But then he has the Metal Gear headband on.
Momos represent.
Thank you, Elena.
Also, mint stinky.
No, I just feel like your chat room is just so tiny compared to your monitor.
My chat room takes up like half my monitor.
Okay, you guys, she opens her chat, like she pops it out.
Yeah, and I make it bigger.
And then she like, yeah.
I control F.
It's not control F.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, but I do that on my keyboard.
Okay, well, I zoomed.
But now, see, there's less messages.
But that's the thing.
You pop it out and you make it like... I make it like this big.
It takes up like this.
Yeah, but then I can't see my OBS.
I don't need to see your OBS.
I need to see my OBS.
It's your house.
It's your kingdom.
You are stinky.
The momos are minted.
By the way, I didn't miss any stinkies, did I?
Is somebody keeping track?
Mint stinky, just in case I missed one.
Stinky, extra stinky.
Extra stinky.
Oh my goodness, I have to say about one of your cats.
I felt so bad.
Yesterday, she just kept staying in my legs.
Yeah, so basically, if you sleep with your legs bent, she likes to sleep in the back of your knees.
One time, I had my legs closed, right?
Just laying stick figure man emoji.
And she pried my legs open to lay in between my legs.
She forces her way into any little...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go ahead.
No, she... so I like... I move...
Also, sorry everybody, I just woke up, so I need a second to kind of awaken.
Oh, yeah, they know.
She was in my legs.
She was in my legs and then I moved to, you know, move myself because I didn't realize she was sleeping there.
She goes, meow.
But she's upset with me for moving and I'm like, you came into my space.
No, no, no.
And that's what it is.
That's the difference of having a cat.
Like when you have a cat, you know that the cat is... that's their domain.
Oh, stinky.
Oh, am I getting too loud?
Yeah.
Oh, sorry.
Stinky.
Stinky mint.
Also, yesterday I sent Mint like two videos.
So both cats were in my bed, which was fine.
I was just on TikTok.
And then they both started licking each other.
Yeah, that's what cats do.
And they kept licking each other for a long time.
And I was like, nice.
Good for you guys.
Yeah, they were...
What is it my turn to get licked?
Oh.
Sorry, I just beat the mic.
Yeah, I made the settings for the mic to stay here.
Why did you pick it up?
Mint, what is it my turn to get licked?
I can't stare up.
I can't look at you.
I'm sorry.
So it's a dominance thing?
Who's licking who?
Like...
The one who licks is the dominant one.
And the licky is the...
Is the submissive one.
So basically they're fighting.
They were arguing.
They were like in mid-battle in your bed.
You know?
And I was just...
I'm like, okay guys, enjoy.
Licky.
Mm-hmm.
Licky, licky, licky.
I do have to say one of your cats is definitely stinky.
They're both very stinky.
I think all cats kind of smell a bit.
I think that's very normal.
But one of your cats went number two.
And I was sitting like...
Again, it's very normal.
If anybody's ever had a cat...
When a cat goes to the bathroom, it's gonna smell for a second.
But your cat...
I even told you.
I was like, you know what?
Let's go for lunch.
Let's get out of here.
We did leave the house.
I was like, this is atomic.
To be fair, she has...
Yeah.
She has butt issues.
Yeah, she has tummy issues and stuff.
So it is very valid.
But yeah, it was to the point where I said...
I'm like, you know what?
Let's go for lunch a little early.
It was not...
It was a little crazy.
It was a little...
Yeah, sorry for my stinky cat.
Can you call me stinky?
Stinky.
Oh my God, it feels weird possessing your body.
What are these?
Do you feel your...
Look, because you're possessing me, it's making you lean forward.
I know.
Here, momos.
This is what you wanted.
Stop.
Someone's just like, play the game.
Oh yeah, do you chat a lot before you play games?
Depends.
I've chatted...
I've chatted sometimes between like 30 minutes.
But sometimes it depends.
You're tired.
You also have...
Demons in my brain.
You do have demons in your brain.
I want to do my laundry, everybody.
That's basically...
I want to like do a lot of laundry.
Yeah, she wants to wash her underwear.
And my socks.
It's like the worst thing.
I'm going to have to disinfect my washing machine after this.
I want to wash my socks.
Socks.
But other than that, without going too much into detail, Thanksgiving was great.
I had a great time.
Oh, something really funny happened today.
Okay, so yesterday I met your grandmother.
Yeah.
She asked me to call her by a nickname, which I started right away.
It's my grandma's gang name.
Yeah.
Oh, that's why.
Okay.
So I've been calling her by her gang name and it was great.
Awesome.
That's why she was like really excited that someone was calling her by her gang name.
Oh, by her gang name.
I see, I see.
So when I first was asking where she's from, she says, yes.
And then she tells me where she's from and she goes...
She goes, guess?
Sorry, I know I'm interrupting.
No, no, go, go, go.
Please, you're doing great.
But she's like, guess.
And then you're like, you didn't hear her at first.
And you were like, what?
Oh.
And then you realize and you're like, oh.
And then my grandma just immediately just says...
She doesn't even give you a minute to guess.
But she then...
The first thing she says about the place where she's from and she's like, the drugs are really good there.
And I was like, yeah, I bet.
I bet.
My grandma's pure.
Don't say that about my grandma.
No, but my favorite thing happened today.
We saw her grandmother again.
And because, you know, that's what two women do when they're about to get married and be in love.
So we saw her grandmother again.
And as she came in, I was like, oh, hi, Cookie, which is just how I call her.
It's kind of her nickname.
And she just looks at me, looks at Mint, looks over at like other people.
And just you can tell she has no idea who I am.
Because I was waiting for my sister.
She had no idea.
She looked at everybody like, who's this bitch?
Yeah, she was like, who the hell?
She was so... and then at the end...
I thought it was really funny that you... so my sister announced she was pregnant.
And I thought it was really funny that you were just like, oh, yeah.
And by the way, Mint and I are a couple.
To my mom.
And she was like, what is going on?
And I was like, no!
No!
It was just absolute chaos.
I wanted to leave immediately.
And that... another thing.
So today, after you and I were leaving, your grandmother went, oh, you were here?
Oh, yeah.
My grandma then looks at me and she goes, Mint?
I was like, yeah, grandma.
And she's like, you were here the whole time?
Yeah, grandma, I was here.
I learned something, though, about her catchphrase.
There was a phrase that she said once.
Where she said, if you come up behind me, you better fight me or fuck me.
And she...
Yeah, guys, I'm basically Akarin from YuruYuri, if you know.
If you know, you know.
Anyway, my grandma once said that.
And I told it to my sister.
I was just like, man, I once said that to some people.
And they thought it was really funny.
And my sister told me some extra lore about that.
And she said...
My grandma has said that before.
But she has said that she learned it.
I won't say who.
But she learned it from a famous serial killer.
Who she once talked to.
And the guy...
It was crazy.
The guy was just like, yeah.
That's how you have to live your life.
And I'm like...
There are famous serial killers.
Like, I've heard of this person.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So...
Grandma!
Man, your grandma is so cool.
She loved me.
When she did remember me, she loved me.
She asked me to kiss her.
Yeah, my grandma did ask for a kiss.
As I was leaving, I gave her a little hug and a head shake.
And she was like, can I get a kiss?
But she was like, I don't get a kiss or something.
It was like either one of those.
No, no, she asked for a kiss.
She asked for a kiss.
The thing is, my lips are a little chapped.
So I've been using chapstick.
But if they weren't chapped, I'd give her a kiss on the lips.
Make her happy in her last few years, you know?
Yeah, if you want to come back.
I mean, you were like, I'm coming back next year.
Oh yeah, your mom misunderstood.
She's like, you're coming for Christmas?
I'm like, no, no, no, no.
It was really fun.
I do have to say, it was very funny when your sister gave the announcement.
The way she made it sound was she talked about a pet.
And she was like, oh, this pet is getting a sibling or something.
And your reaction was, the pet is pregnant?
And I knew, I was like, oh, she's pregnant.
Instantly, like I said it.
And it's like, you were just like, wow, you're getting another pet?
You were like, the pet is pregnant?
I love that pet though.
I love that pet.
It was great.
Thank you for having me over.
It was a good time.
Did you like American Thanksgiving?
It was great.
Even though it was like very non-traditional?
No, but I saw people's photos.
We had the casserole, which is super.
The green bean thing.
We had the sweet potato thing.
We had the turkey and the cranberry sauce.
That's like all Thanksgiving is, no?
Oh, yeah.
Sometimes my mom would make a stuffing.
There was like no stuffing.
We did have pie, but also we bought macaroons.
Can we get the entire Mint family's first impressions of Matara?
I mean, I think your grandma liked me.
The times that she remembered me, she liked me.
My mom really liked you.
She thought you were really funny.
I get that a lot.
My sister probably had no...
Probably no strong opinion.
Your sister is like living her life in her own land.
She does her own thing.
Her afterlife is crazy.
Yeah.
I think the pet liked me, too.
I think your pets like me.
Yeah?
Yeah, they keep cuddling in my bed.
Yeah, that's because that's a place they don't usually get to sleep.
It's because I'm there.
No.
It's because your bed is usually a couch that instead she likes to...
Pies will like grab it.
But yeah, Mata is taller than my entire family is.
Yeah, that's true.
Well, I mean, you're like a space bug.
Yeah, I'm a tall cockroach.
I'm like a six feet tall cockroach, obviously.
I'm taller than everybody.
Yeah.
Was your...
Was your mother's husband very tall?
No.
I really went around that one.
It was great.
It was a lot of fun and everybody was very nice and polite and it was nice.
It was a good time.
I have to say, like, I think it's really good that I was there.
Because otherwise, like, your sister was a little late to dinner.
Oh, yeah.
She was like three hours late.
Yeah, I would have just been there with my mom and my grandma.
Yeah, so...
Just sitting there.
So it was nice that, like, you know...
Yeah.
So, yeah, I wanted to go home.
She did.
I was ready to leave as soon as I walked through the door.
Yeah.
But then we went out and we had fun today.
Yep.
And we went shopping a little.
Shopping.
We bought some skincare, which is always fun.
We bought some skincare.
We bought some snackies.
Snackies!
I have some bubble tea.
I have bubble tea, too.
Yeah.
And we're about to play a scary game.
I just... I need y'all to know, I might not finish.
Like, you probably will have to finish for me.
No, I think I wrote here...
Matara is a baby, so we may not finish.
We'll see how far she gets.
Listen, it's rare that I get to finish, so...
Scary video game.
I finish sentences, too, huh?
Yeah, I meant scary video games.
Uh-huh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What was... where did I get scared with you that you're like, oh...
Oh, we were watching a stream and this guy was playing, like...
It's kind of like I'm on observation duty type of game.
It was like an exit eight.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, which is also observation duty.
And there was, like, a few jump scares.
And they would get me every time.
You would lunge at me.
You'd be like...
But, yeah.
Also, no, I'm possessing Matara, so we can't fix the feature.
There's actually... that was part of the technical issues.
And I just said, screw it.
So, sorry.
Sorry.
Is this or I am just a pinch on screen.
Yeah, pretty much.
So, you guys...
Yeah, pick one.
Beggars can't be choosers, everybody.
Agreed.
Okay, thank you.
Sorry, I'm really salty about it because I've spent a lot of time trying to fix it.
She did.
I had a great time.
I took a nap.
Yeah, she didn't do anything.
And then I sat here.
I did all the work.
And now people are paying you for me to call you Stinky, which again, reminder, $20 and I call men Stinky.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a bargain deal for today only.
Oh, Black Friday deal, everybody.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Buy one, get one Stinky.
That's good.
Spend $20, get one Stinky.
What else?
There's like...
Again, I'm very...
Like, we didn't do much.
All I did was I came over.
I took a ton of naps.
I ate all your snacks.
Yeah.
I cuddled your cats.
You slept a lot.
I slept a lot.
But I'm tired.
I barely slept in the previous part of my trip.
Yeah, she spent all...
She was just like, oh, yeah, I hung out with my actual friends, so I'm gonna go to Mint's place.
And now I'm gonna just sleep the day away.
Mint, you're Stinky.
Stinky.
Not Stinky.
You could be if I spell things.
Mint, you're Stinky.
Yeah, it's a special one.
See who it's from.
I know, I saw.
We're doing a Eurobeat song for Christmas.
Oh, my God.
Spoilers.
It's Last Christmas.
Oh, they know.
It's because she fundraised $15,000 for charity.
Last Christmas, I gave you my heart.
The very next, Mint, you're Stinky, you need a part.
This year, Mint, you're Stinky, save you from tears.
Give it to someone special.
Yeah, no, and I told you.
It's one of those things where I feel...
I feel like when you're kind of new friends with somebody, you always feel like you gotta entertain them and you gotta be on your best behavior.
But when you're really close friends...
At one point, we were sitting watching a stream and I just looked at Mint and I said, Sorry, I'm being quiet.
I know.
Also, Mint, you're Stinky, Mint, you're Stinky.
No, I was so blessed in that moment.
I thought I was gonna go back to heaven because I was just like, Wow, she shut up for five minutes.
Maybe I should just...
Here, I'll just go down here.
And then it's not like...
You're like a little baby.
Then it looks like your stream, but I'm just kind of chilling here.
So cute.
Yeah.
I love it.
Or I can sit upon your teat.
Upon my teat?
Yay!
Wow.
I'm just wedged in there.
I think you should be a little bigger.
Okay.
Yeah, honestly, I've just been kind of like disassociating a lot.
Just chilling, relaxing.
I keep getting people...
I told Mint, I had so many people message me for Thanksgiving.
Also, Mint, you're Stinky.
And it was all very nice.
It was all like, Oh, you know, not happy birthday.
Happy Thanksgiving, et cetera, et cetera.
And I just opened the message.
And I'm like, Oh, I'll get to it when I go back.
Wait, what did you say?
I disassociated.
Where like, even if people are messaging me on Discord or anything or Twitter, I'm like, Oh, I'll get to this next week.
I really needed chill time for the brain.
Yeah, you...
I've been...
Honestly, I was like, I wonder if this stream is going to happen.
I'm down.
Yeah.
All right, fix your brightness.
Left and right.
I knew that.
I need to see a little bit because I am blind.
Why don't you get glasses?
Because.
Watch out, the gap in the door.
It's a separate reality.
The only me is me.
Are you sure the only you is you?
Also, Mint, you're Stinky.
Stinker.
Let's see.
Cockroach.
You.
Mint, you're Stinky.
And thank you, Avelion.
Thanks, Avelion.
Oh, are you OK?
I was headbanging and my headphones came off.
Oh, my gosh.
How does it feel playing this game?
Didn't you say you always wanted to play this game?
I did.
I didn't realize we started.
Oh, fuck.
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh, you might have to move your don't know on the screen.
The super chat.
Why?
Because it's covering some of the...
What are you talking about?
Never mind.
Yours is so big.
It takes up the whole screen.
Uh-oh.
It's almost midnight.
Yoink.
Oh, can I run?
I forget.
I don't remember.
Oh, the audio is muted?
Oh, I'm so sorry, guys.
Oh, my bad.
There you go.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
It should not be muted now.
Yes.
Alright, so I already know that I just have to run every time I hear anything.
One stinky.
Mint, you're stinky.
But there's like some...
There's like sometimes it won't let you proceed until you do the thing that it wants you to do.
Repeating a sequence of numbers in a loud voice.
Mint, you're stinky.
No!
Oh, my god.
This is creepy.
Yeah.
See, it's not even scary right now.
See, you're fine.
I'm fine.
How often do you play horror games?
Never.
Amanda, I hope you had a wonderful Thanksgiving.
Thank you.
Also, Mint, you're stinky.
I never... When's the last horror game I played?
I played Stalker and it was so scary I had to keep leaving the game.
No way.
Yeah.
I'm afraid that if I scream, I might get scared and fart.
Do it now.
It's your birthday, Amanda!
Pussy.
Sing happy birthday, but Metal Gear... Yeah, I can sing it like that.
Happy birthday.
Congratulations.
Happy birthday with salutations.
Happy birthday.
May your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
Spooky.
Sometimes you have to zoom in on things.
I think it's left.
Click the left.
I think it's L3 to zoom.
No, click that.
Oh.
Is it?
Can you... Yeah, yeah, see?
It zooms in a little bit.
Yeah.
Old hag plays video games for the youth.
It literally is like watching a grandma pick up a controller.
Yeah, this is the actual PS4 version.
I still have it on my PS4.
Thank you.
How much did you buy it for, or did you just never delete it?
You were one of the lucky ones.
I was one of the lucky ones, baby.
Sorry, one second.
My breast is itchy.
Oh my god.
Okay, one second.
Let me go back just to make sure I didn't...
You missed Anthony's stinky.
Mint stinky!
Mattar is definitely stinkier.
I, yesterday, or this morning, no, yesterday, she was like, Mattar, do you have soap?
And I was like, damn, she hates me.
She hates me.
I was like, she is calling me out.
She's like, do you need soap?
Do you need shampoo?
I was like, fuck.
Yeah, well, I mean, you know.
No, I appreciate it.
And yes, I do have soap.
Can you not just...
Sorry, nothing.
It was the...
You scared me more than anything else.
Oh my god.
Yeah, sometimes...
What's that sound?
Stop, you're scaring me.
No.
This is just a...
Shit, that was so loud.
Oh my god.
Okay, I have a feeling...
Here, let's switch spots.
This mic is way more sensitive than this other mic.
Let's switch spots.
I worry this might not pull as far.
Oh, the controller.
Oh, I think she's following you.
I think we might die.
She's following me?
Yeah, so basically, the ghost lady follows you around.
How long do I have?
I don't know.
Maybe we're fine.
So when does she kill you eventually?
There's like... eventually.
I don't remember.
Do you ever see her follow you behind or no?
You can.
Yeah, you can turn around and see her.
What's on here?
Oh.
Uh oh.
Mint, I'm terrified.
Mint, like, I am terrified.
Mint, I don't want to play this game anymore.
I don't know when she...
I don't know when she shows up, I'll be honest.
Okay, so there's certain things we gotta find to open the door, right?
Yeah.
I can't remember.
Hold on.
I'm gonna get a walkthrough up for us.
Oh, the bathroom just opened.
Oh my god, we're gonna see the meat baby!
Oh, the ugly baby, good memories.
Oh wait, there's something here that's gonna, like, shut the door.
Stop, stop, stop, stop, stop.
Wait, I'm actually getting kind of scared.
How do I open the door?
Uh, I don't know.
Hold on.
P, T, walkthrough.
Thanks, Kojumbo, for...
You're a little confused.
Try, um...
Try, okay, try pressing in.
Like, press the analog stick.
And zoom in on the hand, like...
Zoom in...
You have to look, you have to zoom in inside the door.
So go to the door, and zoom in.
Zoom.
Zoom, no, don't, move forward, zoom!
Analog?
Okay, which one is it?
Yeah, you have to press.
Oh, it's not working.
Huh.
Oh my god, I feel like she's about to grab me.
Now that you've scared me.
Hold on, I'm watching a walkthrough, or reading a walkthrough.
Oh, oh, oh, I zoomed in, wait.
And now what?
Oh, is it R3?
Oh, I thought it was...
Yeah, it's the other button.
Oh, okay.
That's you.
Oh, my headphones.
Zoom in on the baby.
This is crazy.
Okay, keep going.
Your neighbors are gonna think there's a murder.
Keep going, keep walking.
Keep walking, keep walking.
Is she behind me?
I don't know!
Oh wait, she might be there.
Oh, there she is.
What does that mean?
I don't remember.
Hold on.
I think you have to walk towards her.
But don't scream, please.
Hold on, I'll lower your mic.
I'll lower your mic a little.
Oh no, she's gone.
Just keep going.
Now do you see why I don't play scary games?
You're scaring me, I don't know.
Oh, look up.
No, no, you tried to kill her.
No, it was back there.
I think she stands on the balcony, you know.
Why are you going back towards her?
You said look back!
No, no, no.
Someone in chat said look up.
Time to go meet the meat, baby!
Oh, there's a flashlight.
Zoom in on the light.
And pick it up.
Where is it?
There you go, zoom in.
God, this is like watching Grandma.
And my mouth is open.
I know, you're like...
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay, nice.
Got the meat, baby.
Now we get to see...
I know something scary is going to happen.
No, we're going to see the meat, baby.
And he's going to talk to us.
It's just the meat, baby.
Don't remember this violin.
I can't get out of here yet.
God, what a scary game.
Oh yeah, you have to look into the mirror.
There you go.
It opened.
Oh, it's opening?
That's me.
That's you, actually.
Hold on.
Sorry, I'm being quiet, y'all.
This is like genuinely kind of scary.
Oh, it opened.
I see, I see, I see.
You can leave.
Oh no.
Eventually.
Yeah, it is really scary, isn't it?
I love PT.
I'm so glad.
I'm almost so glad this game didn't come out because I don't think I would have been able to finish it.
It'd be so scary.
Outlast Trials Collab.
Outlast Trials is just kind of...
Are you okay?
Yeah.
She's like...
She's sunk into her chair, you guys.
Yeah, I don't think we should...
Oh yeah, we are getting OD.
Oh gosh, I'm not ready.
What's OD?
It's gonna be Kojima's new game.
New horror game.
Oh no.
I know.
Okay, hold on.
Is that her by us?
Is that her coming up on our...
If she comes up behind me.
Okay, so yeah.
Now, I think this is when she starts...
Yeah.
Don't touch that dial.
Okay, it's not working.
Okay.
Oh man, she's gonna be behind us.
Damn, we died so fast.
What happened?
Oh my god.
Thanks for the stream, everybody.
I had a really fun time.
Oh my god.
What the hell?
How did she kill you so fast?
Don't touch that dial now.
You play for like a second.
Here, just put the controller down, take a rest.
So we restart from like the start start.
Yeah, I think so.
How did she get me so fast?
I did nothing.
I don't know.
Thanks for the raid, by the way.
Thank you for the raid.
How did she kill us so fast?
Is it because we kept walking?
Oh, he says don't look behind you.
And I think that's when exactly you looked behind.
Oh wait, maybe it says it'll trigger a new loop.
It does?
Give me like a second and then we'll go into it again.
I'm genuinely like...
You could tell I'm being quiet.
Like I just sank back into my chair and I'm like I just gotta go with it.
She literally was like shrimping in the chair.
Just like...
Oh, God.
The raiders are now deaf.
Again, raiders, just a reminder, Black Friday special for $20.
No, what do you mean reminder?
For $20, I will call Mint Stinky.
It's all the power I can get.
It makes me feel dominant.
Dominant.
I'm the one that will be licking Mint.
That was a great joke.
Yeah, thanks.
I'm proud of you.
I know.
The more I'm scared, the less I yap.
It's true.
What's that sound in the corner?
You hear that?
She is freaking out.
She's like...
What is that?
She grabbed for my arm.
Oh, my God, that scared me more than you.
Oh, God.
Also, Mint Stinky.
Stinky.
Stupid fucking bag.
Sorry for my language.
I can't believe it scared me.
Are you sure?
Alright, so I'm supposed to listen to him and obey.
A man listens, a slave obeys.
Yeah, I don't think this is a new loop because it's like we're continuing from the darkness.
I don't hear her though.
Okay, so here...
Wait, wait, wait, don't tell me, don't tell me.
Okay.
Oh,
here she comes, here she comes.
You can hear her footsteps?
I can't, can you?
No.
Oh.
Can you?
God.
Oh, God.
It's so scary.
Oh, the door is closed.
I'm not turning back.
No, he's gonna say it again.
I can't do this.
Don't scream at me, please.
She's gonna come get us again.
Here she comes, here she comes.
I'm taking off my headphones because I don't want to hear you scream.
Don't look back.
Oh, God.
Now is she gonna come get us?
You're gonna get grabbed.
204863.
Oh, my God.
No, no, no, no, no.
No!
Don't do it.
Are you sure?
Because now...
I think you can try if you want.
Now he says to look behind you.
Also, Min's stinky.
Stinky!
She's standing right behind us.
I know.
I can hear her moaning.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
Are you ready for another jump scare then?
I think you can walk backwards and she won't get us, right?
Okay, so here...
Oh, my God.
Shut up, Lisa.
Go away, Lisa.
Go away.
Okay, look...
Zoom in.
Right click on the bat.
It's gonna do a thing.
Or it should.
Oh, I see.
You're supposed to do the puzzle.
Yeah, yeah.
Lisa!
That's you.
That's not...
Oh, maybe it doesn't work.
Um, Lisa?
Go away.
Oh, wait.
Oh, it's chocolate.
Someone said press X.
There you go.
Onwards.
Easy.
Easy puzzle.
Tearing me apart when I'm with you.
When you're apart.
Baby.
Oh, baby again.
Onward.
Boob.
That was...
Something stinks here.
Mint does...
Can I tell them the secret?
So...
What?
No, okay.
Hold on.
Tell me first before you tell them.
I don't...
I think it's fine.
Because it's embarrassing for me.
What?
In another dream of mine, maybe I watched you play this.
Uh-huh.
Oh, my God.
I can hear them calling to me from...
Oh, I hear her.
The other side?
I hear her right behind us.
I don't know how to like...
Oh, there she is.
Oh, my God.
No, no, no.
I didn't have my sound on.
I know.
So, I couldn't...
I couldn't...
So, you have no idea.
But I still kept getting scared.
I still kept getting scared.
Because of the jump scares.
Turn that way.
Just keep going.
Leave her alone.
Let her go.
So, I just don't look behind is basically my whole thing.
I think so.
I'm killing it.
Easy baby game.
Right.
People are saying look up.
What?
Oh, my God.
What's wrong?
The lamp.
Here is where you look up, you guys.
Right?
It's this part.
Uh-oh.
So, I don't...
Nasty.
I look up, right?
Yeah, you can look up.
Yeah.
Is that a fridge?
What is that?
Nasty.
When this game came out...
There is something up there.
Look up.
Up here?
Oh, no.
There, right there.
From...
Wait.
Forgive me, Lisa.
There is a monster inside me.
Go away, Lisa.
Oh, fuck.
I'm gonna lift myself up a little bit.
Okay.
Sorry, I'm being so quiet, everybody.
I am, like, actually terrified.
That's...
That's literally you.
That's your inner thoughts right now.
Yeah.
I'm more afraid...
Am I going to the bathroom?
I don't remember.
Hold on.
Let me just go to see.
Little baby.
Little ugly baby.
Do I just keep going to, like, the same door over and over and over again?
Like, what's the prerogative?
There is...
Okay, hold on.
Move under the fridge, down the stairs.
Because it's gotta say, hell.
Or, hello, or whatever.
By the phone.
I'll come back and see if I can look at the phone.
Yeah.
The one right there.
On the right.
I like how everybody knows the game by heart.
Everyone's like, oh, you gotta go to the phone.
You gotta...
No, it doesn't...
Oh, wait.
Yeah, it doesn't say it.
By the phone?
Oh, wait.
Right...
Right there.
See the hello?
Yeah.
I think you zoom in on it.
Okay.
Just to make sure.
Alright, now go back...
Go to...
Continue onward.
That's a lot of pills.
Yeah.
Did I zoom in right?
Or no?
I mean, we'll see.
Hold on, hold on.
You're moving...
There, see?
There's an L.
Huh.
L?
Bozo?
Yeah.
Thanks for laughing.
It wasn't that funny.
Alright.
L Bozo.
Get fridged.
Get jelloed.
I don't know.
Okay.
That wasn't another L.
Hold on now.
Okay, now go look at the hello.
Keep looking at the hello, I think.
What's wrong?
What?
Oh god, why'd you look back?
Why'd you look back?
Okay, keep...
I think you can keep going.
I think you just keep looking at the hello until you take all the words, right?
Where are you going?
What?
You said to keep looking at the hello.
Yeah, and go.
Like you look at it and then walk.
Oh, I think that's what we didn't do last time.
Because it was like the most repetitive puzzle.
Oh my god.
Whoa, chill out baby.
Oh wait, no?
Oh, look away then look back.
Okay, we gotta...
Look away and look back, don't look...
Okay.
L is for look behind you, Matara.
Suck it.
It.
You suck it.
Suck it.
L like in mint stinky.
Alright, so I look away and then I look back.
Why do you look that way?
Okay, now look at it.
Oh, see?
Now look away.
Now look back.
Okay, now you can go.
Low, that's it.
Now look at that.
Oh!
What?
Oh, it's the lamp.
I should've let you pay for dinner.
Since we're doing this game.
I tried.
She did.
I don't wanna let this break.
She also ordered her baby tamago sushi.
I did order baby tamago sushi.
I can
hear them calling me from hell.
Actually, we did never truly complete this though, because I think you need a mic for...
Oh, yeah.
Oh, fuck.
I'm drunk.
Yeah.
Now we're running.
We're running?
Yeah, it's like a maze.
Oh, mint?
Yeah.
Which way am I running?
I don't know.
Just keep going forward.
Keep on going.
Yeah, we have to look for a hole in the wall.
I think it will be pretty...
No, that's a toilet.
That's a hole in the floor.
Here?
No, that's an eyeball.
Mint, I'm about to get eaten.
No, no, no.
This is just part of it.
Just keep on going, keep on going.
That wasn't it, that wasn't it.
No, that's a door.
Sonic's number one.
Sonic's on the run.
Watch out for Sonic X.
Sonic X.
We should have done a karaoke.
You have to look up.
Oh, do you want to do karaoke instead?
Yeah, we should have.
We should have done a karaoke, Mint.
Instead of this.
Honey, why are you calling me?
Whenever you want to tap out, we can do karaoke.
That's a hole, too.
That's a door as well.
You do have to look for the hole, though.
I can't be running and looking for the hole.
Is that over there?
Oh, fuck.
I don't know.
Ok, just keep going.
Maybe not.
Someone said look for the picture frame lying on the ground.
I need healing.
Ok, don't look so far down, though.
Keep going.
I need healing.
Going to the bathroom?
Oh my god.
Go over there.
Ok, now zoom in into the hole.
You have to actually peep.
You have to be like a real peeping tom.
Ladies, are we showering?
Don't lean in.
Don't actually lean in.
You're going to scare yourself.
It's because I can't see from far, right?
Oh, we're looking on the wrong side.
Sorry guys, I really don't remember so much about this at all.
Ok, so...
Go?
We're looking...
I don't know.
Is that her?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Mint, don't say that.
I don't know if she's here or not.
She'll always be behind you, though.
She's always technically...
No...
They're saying that she's not in this area.
God, it's really making me motion sick, though.
They make it obvious.
I think you had to still look at that, though.
So that something triggers.
Something triggers.
The baby's speaking.
Oh, we passed it.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Something just popped.
No, no, no.
You have to keep going.
Are you sure?
Yep.
I saw.
Look, look, look.
Painting on the ground, leaning on the wall.
Ok.
So, leave?
I know.
Here, let me see it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, let me look away for a second, because that is...
Painting on the ground.
Leaning against the wall.
I think I passed it.
The way she walks there is like waddling around.
Waddling around.
I think our brightness is so dark, I literally can't see anything.
And I made it, like, not as dark.
I know.
I can't... I don't know how everybody is seeing it.
It's too dark.
I can't see shit.
I found it.
Oh, wow.
How did you find that?
Because I'm a genius.
Oh, fuck.
Wait, is that it?
No, keep going.
It's not letting me peep anymore.
Oh, yeah, nevermind.
There's gonna be...
There should be a message that, like...
Appears after you peep through.
Oh, my God.
I don't use this controller.
I have to just keep holding.
You know, I don't think you have to...
I don't think you have to look around.
You can just hold down and listen.
Taking all the fine upstanding folk got their welfare cut, got their jobs pulled from under them.
No, no, no, keep looking.
Does it restart every time?
I don't know, we'll find out.
Oh, God.
Yeah, okay.
We're listening to Lisa's final moments.
Oh, boy, we're about to get to the picture part.
Yeah, you know what to do.
Now's the time.
No!
It's his old text message.
Oh, we have to listen to the whole thing over and over again.
We have to stop, please.
Okay.
Okay,
no turning back now.
Okay, I do not turn back.
Run to the exit.
Why am I walking so slow?
That's how you were walking before.
So if I turn back now, she'll be behind me?
I have no idea, just go.
Yeah, yeah, I'm not turning back, don't worry.
Just stop.
Just for, just go.
Okay.
I'm not turning back.
Sorry, everybody, I am terrified.
There it is.
That's why I'm just like...
That really did give me motion sickness, oh my God.
I know.
Made me feel really...
Everything's fine, baby.
It just takes some time.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, God, oh, God, oh, God.
Oh, it's so dark, it's so dark.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Okay, it's not, it's not midnight.
Oh, it's midnight.
That's good.
Nice.
Okay, and it's nice and bright.
My favorite.
Meet baby.
Oh, too late, I didn't look at him.
That's fine.
I can hear her calling me from hell.
What just happened?
Something glitched when I looked up.
Yeah, I know.
Oh, no.
Yeah, see it glitching?
Yeah.
Oh, no.
I don't know how often it's supposed to glitch.
Oh, it's the number.
Yeah.
Do I go back to the phone?
No, I don't think we search for the photos.
Just after, a little bit's gonna happen.
I like how you're just moonwalking.
Oh, don't ever turn around, she'll get you.
What are you doing?
The phone.
No.
What do you mean no?
The numbers.
I'll be heading there now.
You're laughing because you know everything.
I did this before, I paid my dues.
I died.
The only me is me.
Are you sure the only you is a you?
How did I die?
No, that wasn't... I don't think that's technically dying.
Oh, oh, I'm crawling in my skin.
These wounds they will not heal.
Is the little bag still there?
I'm gonna go check.
Yeah.
Oh.
Hey there.
He's like, I'm not talking to you.
Loser.
Is that technique... I'm sorry guys, I've been... Oh, there we go.
All right, now I'm gonna help you out here.
Look down there.
And... Oh, is it not yet?
Do we have... Oh wait, there we go.
Okay.
Now go back.
Go back.
Okay, now we got one picture.
Okay.
One picture?
All right, hold on.
Hold on.
Can't on the clock.
Clock.
Maybe moonwalk?
Moonwalk?
I wanna really try and beat this though.
Oh, oh.
Okay, go, go, go.
Just go, go, go.
Do not stop.
Do not, do not, just go.
Just go to the next loop.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
Go to the next loop!
Okay, now...
Keep going, keep going, keep going.
Go down there, look down at the teddy bear.
And, no, no, no, keep going, keep going.
She might grab us, so, you know, it's not just looking down.
Or, like, looking behind anymore.
Where is it?
Oh god.
I don't want her to grab us.
Yeah, she's, like, always here.
Yeah, I hate it.
Makes me want to throw up.
I wonder how people figured it out the first time.
Like, the teddy bear and stuff like that.
It's by the standing soda can.
Okay.
By the standing soda...
Oh, I see.
Okay, no, no, no, keep going, keep going.
Alright, go, it's, like, there.
Now zoom.
There it is, there it is.
Nice.
Alright.
Yeah, I would have never figured this out.
Beneath the window near the phone.
Okay, just keep going, keep going.
I know, right?
This is, like, so...
Oh, wait, sorry.
Lodging the ceiling beam between the foyer and the bathroom.
Okay, so we'll just keep going.
Ceiling beam between the foyer and the bathroom?
Yeah.
I wonder if I... I don't think I have a mic.
Uh, up, look up, look up, look up, up, up.
Oh, no, no, you were... nope.
Where?
Uh, through and around here.
Nope, uh...
Look on this side.
Am I looking in the...
Maybe back a little.
Ceiling.
You can do it without a mic.
You can.
You have to turn around to see it.
We'll start again, we'll start again, we'll start again.
Go, go, go!
Oh my god, I am like, I'm about to get grabbed, I just know it, I'm so scared.
I think you did... no, I didn't do it before.
I didn't have the mic.
We never actually did it.
Uh, keep going, just keep going.
Keep going?
That means she's like right there, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, just keep going.
Just keep going.
Oh, it's red now.
Does that also mean she's haunting?
I have no idea.
Alright, I'm just going to keep walking until she grabs me.
I don't want her to grab.
It's so dark.
Why is it so dark?
Okay, okay, okay.
She's like right there.
But I still hear her.
I know, me too.
Oh, oh no.
Oh no, you're scaring me.
I'm scared.
Somebody said you can check the photo progress.
Oh my god, that scared me.
How was that?
Bitch.
No.
Thanks, Ava.
That scared me.
Alright, where was the painting thingy to go?
I'm looking up there, right?
On those little beams up there?
Yeah, but you're going to have to look...
You're going to have to turn around and look.
No, but why would I have to turn around if I'm over there?
No, because it's behind... it's like on the beam on the other side.
Not there.
No, no, no, no.
A little turn around here.
Scoot back a little.
I'm so scared she's going to get us.
There it is, there it is.
Are you zoomed in?
I think that's it.
That is it, right?
Hello?
Do you want to try doing it?
No, I'm scared.
Hello?
Okay, keep going.
Alright, the last one...
The last one is in the staircase.
But you have to also...
Oh, nice.
Keep going.
Get the fuck out of here.
Fuck all of you.
Not you, Wisp.
Oh wait, there's one more.
There's one more.
I remember this.
Okay, keep walking a little bit.
Not you, Wisp.
I don't mean like that.
I'm so terrified right now.
I forgot.
Is it this photo?
No?
Okay, never mind.
Keep going.
Alright, go to the pause menu real quick.
Which one?
Options?
I think so.
Are you okay?
Actually, adjust it a little bit.
Give me a minute.
She needs a pause.
Everybody good?
Everybody alright?
No.
I feel good because you've mentally tortured me this whole weekend.
I am just like disassociating.
Alright, press R3.
This?
Oh!
Are you kidding me?
People were never going to find that.
That is the stupidest...
Okay, I say this with love.
This is the stupidest game ever.
I'm not even kidding.
I know.
This game is so dumb.
How are people going to find that?
Okay.
Now this is where we...
This is where we...
Just keep going.
Where it ended for us because...
Oh, the microphone.
Yeah.
Now here...
I don't know what to do here.
I have...
Doesn't the...
I thought the controller had a mic on it.
Hello, can you hear me?
Hello?
It says loop until the clock says 12.
That means 12.
That's wild!
That's 12.
Do we go?
Wait, what do we do?
Wait, don't...
Go?
It doesn't say 12 though.
Retry?
Hold on.
I'm looking.
I don't...
Mine doesn't say...
Oh, wait.
Everything must be attempted after the clock strikes midnight.
Hold on.
Let's wait for the bell.
In order for the phone to ring...
Is that her or is that you?
It's me.
Oh, okay.
Oh, just stand by the clock.
Okay.
Dang it!
We had it.
That timing was so funny.
And then...
Hold on.
Okay.
This is scary because there's a part where you can't move.
And I know you will.
Huh.
Mito isn't playing but she's just distressed.
I know I am.
Yeah, she's stressing me out.
Okay.
So, it's...
Okay, this is what...
The...
Okay, I'm gonna say what the walkthrough I'm reading says, you guys.
And you tell me yes or no.
So, it says...
It must be attempted after the clock strikes midnight.
The player should have a microphone or headset plugged into their controller.
Which I don't have.
In order...
In order for the phone to ring...
Okay, so this is where I stay still.
No, no, no.
Hold on.
In order for the phone to ring, you must hear a baby laugh three times.
Walk ten paces...
Okay, now walk ten steps...
Ten steps exactly and freeze.
Right now or after the clock?
Yeah, so go.
One...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Six...
Seven...
Eight...
Nine...
Ten...
We didn't get a laugh.
Keep going.
Keep going?
Yeah.
Wait until the laugh.
I didn't hear any baby laugh.
And now?
Oh, you have to do it while the bell is ringing?
What?
No, no, don't give one guide.
I don't think so.
No, it said everything has to happen after...
I think she's right behind us.
So, do we just do the loop?
You need to hear the steps.
Yeah.
Is she gonna get us?
I think she's right behind us.
Isn't she?
Teleports behind you.
Teleports behind you?
Nothing personal, kid.
Oh, my mom's house.
I told you, I told you, I forgot Momo at your mom's house.
I lost Momo at her mom's house.
My mom just texted me and said, look what I found in my bathroom and it's a Momo.
I knew it.
Okay, let's wait for the 12.
And then you're gonna have to listen for the footsteps.
So, it's not just one, two, three.
It's like one footstep.
Okay, so I start walking now?
Yeah, I think you can.
So, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, stop.
Okay.
I keep grabbing Mint.
I know.
We have to hear the baby laugh three times.
It was one?
So now, do we... don't move?
Okay.
Remain... it's... okay, the vibrations... the controller might start vibrating, but don't touch anything.
I think we need a second... no, I think we have to get a second one, right?
Lisa, I love you.
Lisa!
Please, Lisa, forgive me.
I am not your husband.
Lisa, I love you.
I love you.
I'm so sorry for what happened to you.
Lisa, please release me from this nightmare.
Release me from my dirty cage.
Please, please.
Someone said they completed this without a mic, so I feel like...
What if you're getting one guide?
No, I've seen several people say that they did this without a mic, unless they had a mic and they didn't realize, you know?
Alright.
What do you propose we do?
Yeah, guys, what do we do now?
I'm scared.
I'm gonna walk.
I think we...
This is where we got stuck before.
Yeah.
You really want us to help?
Yes.
What do you mean?
Alright.
Back in the club.
In the club.
We're all fam.
Oh my gosh.
What do we do after...
Oh, say Jareth into the microphone.
Not Jared.
Like Jareth.
But we don't have the...
Let me look at it.
It has a speaker-looking thing, but...
I don't think that's a mic.
Let's whisper Jareth when the time comes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's do that.
Jareth.
It's a speaker, not a mic, right?
That's what I thought.
Oh my gosh, she's here again.
It is a speaker.
No, the PS5 one is definitely a speaker, but...
Alright, alright, alright.
10 steps.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
Jareth.
I'm like talking into it.
I'm trying to think of...
If I have a mic, I could use...
Jareth.
I have to plug into it.
It's not Jareth.
Wait, what was that?
Oh, nevermind.
Jareth.
Also, Minstinky.
It's Jareth.
Jareth.
Wait, say Lisa.
Just say Lisa.
Lisa.
No, I don't think it worked.
Hold on.
This is so silly.
Hold on, I'm gonna...
Okay, just stand there.
I'm gonna go try and see if I can find a mic.
You don't want me to move at all?
You can't leave me.
I'm scared.
I'm trying to think of a mic right now.
What if I reloop and we talk to the phone?
I got one man for that.
Wait, oh, you have a guy for a phone?
No, no, no.
Some guy said to talk to the phone.
Oh.
Phone, phone, phone, phone.
Okay, so, what's the plan?
PS5 controller.
But this is a PS4.
Loser.
You think you're made of money?
What kind of mic would be good?
Oh, mint, it's green.
Why is it green?
Oh my god, what does it mean?
Momos and wisps, what does it mean?
It means you're good to go.
I don't know.
iPod headphones?
I don't have an iPod.
Uh...
I don't get how Gary gets out too.
That scared me.
What?
It was like a Gary sound effect.
What do you mean, what does that mean?
I don't know, there was like a sound effect that somebody played, I think.
Oh, oh!
It wasn't Akidono.
Wait, wait, this is the for sure solution.
Walk ten steps, say a J name into the mic, but we don't have one.
Then finally stay still, any mic works even if you have the Playstation camera.
You can test mic and PS settings.
A USB mic?
I don't have a USB mic.
A Gary sound effect.
Alright, I need your help with the headphones.
Why?
Ten steps.
Oh, okay.
One...
Two...
Three...
Five...
Six...
Seven...
Eight...
Nine...
Ten...
Okay.
Jared!
Jason!
Wait, this one says...
Stop...
Wait...
Ten steps forwards and stop, baby laughs, don't move again.
After the clock stops ringing, continue to wait until the Lisa music fades.
Is that true though?
That's what we've been doing and nothing happened.
Oh, it's speeding up.
What?
Do I have earbuds with a mic?
Yes, I do have those.
Let me go grab them.
I'm scared.
She left me.
Wisp, she left me.
I'm sorry I'm being quiet for once.
I'm just so scared.
I am my main phantom and I am a stinky little girl.
I am a stinky, stinky little girl.
Welcome back.
I'm right at where you left me.
Okay.
Why is it so green?
I'm right where you left me.
Now I'm here.
I got...
Okay.
Plug this in to the bottom.
Jared!
No, hold on.
The mic is ringing.
Jared!
Oh, but now I can't hear because of the thingy.
Oh, it switched to this.
Okay, take off the headphones and go to this.
Oh, she's moaning.
Jared.
Lisa.
Oh, you guys can't hear it now either.
Uh-oh.
It's okay, it's okay.
She's moaning.
She's just moaning.
She's like...
I'll
unplug it once you guys...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Once it works, you know?
Should we move when she's done moaning?
Maybe.
Oh!
We got a second baby!
We got a second...
Don't move, don't move, don't move.
We got a second baby.
We got another baby.
Okay, what do we do after the second baby laugh?
Do we just wait for baby...
Oh, it's vibrating.
Oh, let it vibrate.
Let it vibrate.
Oh my god, I'm gonna feel.
Oh, don't touch it, don't touch it, don't touch it.
Remain mochiceless until the vibrations cease entirely and the third laugh will trigger.
And then the phone will begin to ring.
Oh!
We got another laugh!
We got a...
Oh, the phone's ringing!
The phone's ringing!
Do I pick it up?
Hold on, hold on.
The phone is ringing, guys.
What do we do?
We can unplug the mic now.
Okay.
Do we...
Do we go get the phone?
Go get the phone?
Zoom in on the phone.
So, turn around.
Go to the phone, go to the phone.
Turn around, turn around.
Oh my god, we're finally doing it!
Zoom in, zoom in.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh!
Now what?
Finish the loop.
Go, go!
Oh my god, I can't believe it!
I finally did it!
And you too!
We finally did it!
We did it!
I can now proudly say...
Wait, the front door!
So, hold on, hold on.
Wait, is it the front door?
Front door, front door.
You little shitheads.
Wait, front door?
Keep going?
Try it again?
Do a zoom on it?
Oh, it's a loop door.
Okay.
Holy, you guys.
So, we're doing fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just, okay, nevermind.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Well, it's a good thing we tried anyway.
Oh my god!
We have officially finished the game!
High five!
Sorry I was so quiet.
I was legit terrified.
Wait, I can't wait to watch this.
Oh my...
Such a drag!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I can't believe it!
I'm so glad this mic worked!
I'm so happy!
Oh my god, I'm turning it up.
It's so cool seeing this on my own monitor and it's from my own PlayStation.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's so awesome.
Oh, it's really nostalgic actually seeing this.
Oh my god!
Seeing this after so long is so nostalgic.
I don't think I've watched it since it first was announced or first figured out.
My heart.
Oh, my heart.
Would've been so good.
Yeah, that was Norman Reedus like way back when.
Yeah, this is Norman Reedus.
Norman Reedus and his initial funky fetus.
This project also had Junji Ito on it.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, it's so weird seeing this.
Oh my god.
This whole game was just the trailer for Silent Hill.
Hills!
Hills, sorry.
Because it's a playable trailer, right?
Yeah.
Oh gosh.
And nobody could beat it.
How were you even going to beat this trailer?
Oh, the Silent Hill music.
I get so excited.
This is so sad.
I cry.
Good job, Atari!
Thank you for the help.
I like how they're like, look, I know we just did this game and you played it, but it has nothing to do with Silent Hill.
I know.
Like, we just, you know.
We just wanted to scare the poopy out of you and that's it.
That was so troll with like the pictures.
It just doesn't make any sense.
You're looping forward just to then see that.
Kajimbo, you really cooked.
He's my coworker now.
I know.
I'm sorry, I need a minute.
I'm like...
I don't do good with scary.
But you're in the game.
Look, you're right there.
I was in the game a lot.
Oh man.
Yeah, you were in the game a ton.
So, thoughts, prayers?
How do you feel?
You finally, you actually beat P.T.
So now, like you never have to do it again.
I can brag about it to people now that I, and I told you that I wanted to do that ages ago.
I know.
So thank you for making my dreams come true.
And on original hardware, like this is, we can just, we teleported, when did this come out?
2008?
No, way later.
This was, this, a 20, 2014, 2015, 2014, 10 years ago.
We teleported ourselves 10 years in the past.
And now, we beat it.
No, I'm not the biggest thing.
Screw you, Lisa.
Yeah.
Oh, well, I mean, she did get murdered.
It's not really her fault.
I like how it has nothing to do with the actual Silent Hill.
That's the crazy part.
Like, this game has nothing to do with it.
Not, well, we'll never know if it did or not.
You say that, but maybe we will.
Unless they, like, reused the...
What if he has, like, a 20 year NDA?
That would be quite, quite wild.
That would be crazy.
I mean, there's a lot of stuff that is the same.
Norman Reedus, The Baby.
Yeah.
What else?
I'm excited for OD.
The new game?
Stop to play Death Stranding.
No, I have to finish Death Stranding.
Did you like it?
From what I played, yeah.
It's hard, it's, it was harder to stream because there were a lot of restrictions for the songs.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it's also just a very quiet game.
Like, kind of, I wanted...
Yeah.
Part of it, like, I almost was like, I don't want to stream this.
I just kind of want to, like, bask in my...
Enjoy it, yeah.
In my adventure, kind of.
But...
I gotta get ready for Death Stranding 2.
And if Death Stranding 2 has Pecora in it...
That would be crazy.
I wonder how they're gonna have her in there.
Let's see if she...
If it's gonna be just, like, a standee.
No, because, basically, with other actors, you would go to a place to deliver things, and then...
I said if, you guys, I said if Pecora's in it, but, you know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I want to see if she's in it.
But you go to, like, a location, and a projection will happen, and you'll talk to a person, and it's usually, like, some famous actor.
So, I think that if they do it like that again, maybe it will be that.
The hologram, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm excited.
Yeah, Conan O'Brien was in it, Junji Ito was in it.
I know they had a ton of monster.
Like monsters?
Energy drink.
Oh, yeah!
Monster energy was in it.
Hold on, let me get more hot water.
Okay.
One moment.
Would you like anything?
No, I'm good, thank you.
Wow.
No, you're good.
You're good.
Recovery.
Wow, that was so good, you guys.
We kind of sped run it.
But I really, since, like, you know, we had watched it before together, I was like...
I think we can speed up, especially for Matoro's sake.
We just speed up the process, but I'm so glad we could actually complete it now.
Everything feels so complete now.
Yeah.
Thanks for the PT, Macy.
Oh, you scared me.
What other games are you playing this week?
What are your plans this week?
I don't know yet.
Did you bring the twin snakes?
Are those yours or mine?
They're yours.
I already ate all mine.
What?
You're eating my twin snakes!
I already ate mine.
Oh my gosh, you guys, we watched the Macy's Day Parade.
Oh, can we talk about that?
That's so funny.
And, so, I don't have television.
I don't have, like, cable or anything like that.
So, I was just like, oh, we'll just put on, like, a YouTube live stream of it.
And it was...
It was...
So funny.
Oh my god, the camera work was terrible.
Yeah.
It was so...
At one point, the guy, like, wiped the camera with his sleeve.
Yeah!
There was no commentators.
It was so great.
Like, grayscale, whatever it's called?
Oh, it was so funny.
Did you just mute me?
No, no, sorry, I was, uh...
She's like, you know what, Watari?
You're done talking.
You're in mic, too, anyway.
They sang Sing on the Sesame Street float.
What?
She kept asking, when's Pikachu coming?
No, I kept asking when Goku's coming.
And then Goku came.
Yeah, it was really desaturated.
It was like, there was no color.
It just looked gloomy and sad.
But there was a Haribo float.
And they had the Twin Snakes on there!
Which means, if they sang Sing on the Sesame Street, and also Twin Snakes, that means there were two Metal Gear references.
In the floats.
That nobody knows but me.
And other Metal Gear fans.
Do you like my Metal Gear display?
I love it.
I was gonna say, you saw a quote at your mom's house.
Oh, yeah!
It was like a Metal Gear quote.
Close to it.
What was it?
You have a picture of it.
Oh, yeah, yeah!
Basically, my mom... No, it wasn't Metal Gear.
Oh, but it was like Metal Gear.
It was Ace Combat.
Oh, my bad, my bad.
No, it's okay.
My mom had this, like, this quote written on her...
Like, live, laugh, love.
Yeah, yeah, something like that.
And, but instead, on the outside of it was the brackets they use in Ace Combat.
So I was like...
My brain rot.
My brain rot's never going away.
So I took a picture of it.
Yup.
Oh, no!
That was the other thing.
Yes, my mom has a sign too that says, the best is yet to be.
And I took a picture of it.
Did you let Matara touch the Pachi slot?
Yeah, I touched it.
I turned it on.
But she didn't play it.
Do you want to play it?
Um, not really.
I'm like, kind of, I'm very tired.
Like, I've been very low energy while I've been here.
And I think you guys can even notice.
Like, I'm just, I'm really tired.
Once you kind of, like, take time off and then you realize, like, oh, I'm actually out of it.
It's kind of disassociating through the day.
She's disassociating.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Someone's like, so no karaoke?
Um, we can do, like, one song.
Yeah.
We can also just yap and see what everyone's up to.
How is everyone else's Thanksgiving?
Yeah, what'd you guys eat?
We're, uh...
Stinky!
Happy Thanksgiving, pumpkin pie.
I love pumpkin pie.
We shared a pumpkin pie.
We did, we did, we did.
I'm Canadian.
It was very, and you accidentally ate from my fork.
I did accidentally eat from my fork.
Yeah, she just, she wanted the indirect kiss.
Oh, no.
Maybe.
No!
It's like we kissed.
Um, crawfish.
Mmm, crawfish sounds good.
Are you Southern?
That sounds like a, sure, that sounds like a Forrest Gump thing.
Crawfish.
Yeah.
Now, now all your energy has gotten, you've completed, I see, I feel like completing PT gave me...
More energy.
It almost gave me new life.
I feel like I'm about to be, I feel like I could become a human again.
We gotta, we gotta make sure that doesn't happen.
Why?
We like you as a ghost.
You'd be too strong as a human.
I think I'm stronger as a ghost.
I get to possess many people.
Yeah, please unpossess me, leave me alone.
Leave me alone.
I'm gonna make your body do unspeakable things.
No, leave me alone, please, Matt.
Yeah.
Hi, honeys, I'm a tarot card.
Why are you leaning in so much?
What do you mean, leaning in?
I'm like, yeah.
Oh, you're like this usually?
Uh -huh.
But my, but the camera's down here.
Hi, honeys, I'm a tarot card.
You're so dumb.
You're so stupid.
What are you doing still?
I feel you, I shouldn't let you pay for dinner.
Why did I buy dinner?
I'm eating your twin snakes.
I hate this.
I feel...
Hold on, I wanna put my head underneath.
Oh, gosh.
You're so dumb.
Everybody be jealous of me.
Please stop.
Stop possessing me.
The first thing you would do if you possessed anybody, you would just gulp their breasts, wouldn't you?
With love.
Tickle, tickle, tickle.
Your little ahoge is tickling me.
Stop.
Yeah, guys.
I know you wanted to go to bed early.
Do you want me to let you talk to them?
Yeah, I'll talk and then you can go.
No, wait, I was gonna help you with your laundry.
It's okay, I'll talk to them tomorrow.
I can sit here and watch you talk with them.
Oh, okay.
I will stare at you while you speak to them.
I don't like the sound of the scraping behind us.
In the game.
Oh, you have the headphones off.
Ew.
Oh, my God.
Oh, God.
It's horrible.
It's disgusting.
Okay, I'm gonna end the stream now.
Thank you, guys.
Bye, everybody.
We love you so much.
Bye-bye.
Here, I'll let you possess your... have your body back for just a moment.
So you can actually say goodbye to them.
Bye, my loves.
It was so much fun being here with you all.
It was so fun.
Bye-bye.
Bye -bye.
Otsumito.
Matara will matane.
Matane.
Bye-bye.
Thank you, everybody.
We love you muchly.